[intro]
Hi there, my name is Tina, also known as Teanayy at youtube.com/iswallflower and I'm here with
Psych2Go today to talk about antisocial behavior versus asocial behavior. I'll be referring to
information from the Psych2Go's article, "An Antisocial is Someone Who Doesn’t Care and Violates Others while
an Asocial is Someone Who Doesn’t Like to Socialize."
So, growing up, I actually had a lot of experiences being called antisocial. I was called antisocial
in the sense that I was too introverted and hermit-like to talk to people. I was very nervous and
scared. That's actually not what an antisocial is at all. Antisocial behavior is actually when you lack
the conscience of your wrongful actions.
Basically, it's when you do something wrong or bad, and you know that it's bad but you just
don't feel bad for it. Antisocial behavior, also known as ASPD, doesn't actually have an exact
cause, but there are a few indicators as to what would increase your chances of having it. Which
would include being male, having been abused as a child, growing up with parents that have
ASPD or having parents that are alcoholic.
As you grow older, there are some behavioral signs that could indicate whether or not you have
antisocial behavior. Which would include cruelty toward animals, resistance to authority,
bullying and lying. What people generally think antisocial is is that they don't want to talk to
people, they don't want to socialize and stuff. That's actually not antisocial behavior but actually
'asocial behavior'.
Asocial behavior is actually when you don't want to socialize with people. What people
generally think is antisocial. Asocial behavior is often found in people that have other disorders,
including personality disorders, mood disorders, autism or schizophrenia.
So, now that you know the difference between asocial and antisocial, what do you guys think?
Were you someone that used to mix up antisocial and asocial behavior before? Or were you
someone that use to be called antisocial when others actually meant asocial?
Let us know what you guys think and all of your experiences in the comments below. If you
enjoy this video, please give it a thumbs up. And, if you'd like to see more psychology
mythbusting, be sure to subscribe this channel at Psych2Go, and be sure to check them
out on Tumblr, Twitter and Facebook. And, if you'd like to see more of me, you can head over to
my channel at youtube.com/iswallflower. Thanks for watching!